people are gonna be dropping some love
you long times potentially I'm sure
it'll be super stereotypical any like
coded language for an Asian person I
expect if I'm or just looking at these
titles it already looks pretty terrible
yeah let's watch this Asian babies were
scared you know what's funny is like I
like don't like kids that much so every
time I was an Asian baby sitter I was
really scared this angle also oh my god
she's upside down like this woman's in
her 20s she's dressed like a little girl
and she had like pigtails like up to
here with like a baby doll crop top and
like shorts he's treating her like a
child
oh god he just like yeah she basically
made on night stick innuendo but she did
it bad like the actual night staying on
oh yeah
Sharon Lee made who knows how to please
okay so now there's like this asian maid
she doesn't speak English and she just
says Oh sex I love sex
[Music]
I think lunch I haven't seen one Asian
guy in this - I realized that it's only
been like Asian women in white man she's
speaking Japanese don't go she was just
speaking English earlier why are you
giving us old men yeah now the masseuse
is naked but the client is not which
makes mrs. the mature and responsible
old man is the horny and uncontrollable
occasion
on the walls of this house there's a lot
of like old Asian men with like funds in
like warrior clothing he sounds like an
animal also she didn't finish that's not
fair it wasn't enjoyable to watch really
I was expecting like we have Asian guy
and oh no I I completely expected age of
girls oh really if you don't grow up in
like a diverse area and you're only
exposed to Asian women like through your
media or through your porn now you're
gonna have a super warped idea of what
it means to be an Asian woman and you're
also probably gonna think that Asian men
just don't exist what crisis point
[Music]